Let's talk a little bit about what I
mean by agentic engineering.
And let's maybe start with a question.
If I were to ask you right now, how are
you using AI in your work? Could you
actually really explain it?
Not just, you know, it helps me code
faster. It can write code really fast,
but like the real workflow.
What you hand off, what you keep, how
you decide in between.
Most engineers can't and that's a little
wild to me because 90% of engineers are
already using AI tools or have used
them. Maybe only half of them are using
them on a regular basis, but that's a
number that's definitely growing all the
time.
And that's the current state.
So, the question isn't whether your team
is using AI, they are. The question is
whether you're getting the most out of
it or you're just kind of auto
completing your way through the day.
That gap between using AI and being able
to articulate how you work with it,
that's what this talk is all about.
And really, I think it represents a
paradigm shift of how we think about AI.
And you know, the history of AI and
software engineering is moving
uh very fast. It's also very
surprisingly short, right? In the 20
early 2020s, we got tools that could
finish the lines for you. You type, you
know, half of a function signature and
the model would guess the rest of it.
You know, kind of like auto complete on
steroids. It's a neat trick.
And then in 2022,
models started to be able to suggest
entire functions, right? You could
describe what you wanted and chat with a
model and maybe get a working
implementation back. And this is where
GitHub Co-pilot first came on the scene
and broke through and millions of
developers started using it. And for the
first time it was starting to seem like
maybe AI wasn't a novelty, maybe it was
generally useful.
But then in 2025, something really
broke. It's, you know, what we're living
in now in 2026. The the models don't
just suggest, they can execute. They can
take a task and break it down and figure
out which files need to be touched and
make the changes and run the tests
themselves and then come back with an
actual pull request.
And so, that's not just fancy auto
complete. It's not just a a faster
horse. It's a collaborator. It's a
different way of working.
And Armin, the creator of Flask for
those Python folks here, put it, I
think, perfectly.
We're no longer just using machines.
We're now working with them.
And that framing, I think, captures this
real shift.
Right? Tools are things that you pick up
and put down. You use a hammer. You
don't work with a hammer.
But the AI coding agents we have today,
they're kind of somewhere more in
between and they're maybe a little bit
more like working with another engineer.
Now, it just happens to be an engineer
who's read every Stack Overflow answer
ever written.
And I think that needs a a mental model
shift. And this is the mental model I
want you to carry through the rest of
this video and honestly through the rest
of your, you know, next couple years of
your career in working with these tools.
I I do think they're still tools, but we
have to think about them differently.
You kind of have to think about your AI
agent as an energetic, enthusiastic,
extremely well-read, often confidently
wrong junior developer.
That junior developer is incredibly
fast. They don't easily get tired. They
don't have any ego about their code.
They'll happily rewrite something six
times if you ask them to.
And they have an astonishing breadth of
knowledge. They've seen lots of
languages. They've seen lots of
frameworks. They've seen lots of
patterns.
But, and this is critical, what they
don't have is judgment. They don't know
your business context. They don't
understand the reasons why you made that
very specific architectural decision 3
months ago.
And they'll confidently write code that
is technically correct and contextually
wrong.
Armand also said that he's gained more
than 30% of time in his day because the
machine is doing a lot of the work.
That's a real gain.
But he's getting that 30% because he
knows what he can hand off and what he
has to keep for himself.
He's not just blindly accepting every
suggestion. He's directing the work.
And that's the difference between using
AI and working with AI. And that's what
agentic engineering actually means.
And so, let's get tactical. If you're an
engineer, how do we really
get good at this?
I think the number one thing to think
about is context engineering.
And here Karpathy says, you know,
context engineering is a delicate art
and science of, you know, filling the
context window with just what needs to
happen for the agent to have the right
context for the right iteration for the
next step.
I think that's really critical for a
couple of reasons. First, context is
expensive, right? Every token you add
into the context is going to add cost
because all of those things, that whole
chat history, is sent back in as a input
tokens every time that you send it.
And
that, you know, can can add up pretty
quickly.
And the other key is that more context
doesn't always mean better results. And
in fact,
um it can make the model actually
dumber.
Right? It's not just about the money.
The quality can degrade as you get over
about 50% full.
And there's lots of things that can trap
you here. And not the least of which
are, you know, the facts that fact that
MCP servers became so popular
that we have a lot of these enabled all
the time now. Well, each one of those
loads more and more context. Uh you
know, more and more input code tokens in
the context.
And and that can be a real problem if
you start getting into this dumb zone
around 50% context.
And
that also isn't the only problem because
not only can more context be a problem,
but bad context can be a problem and can
poison everything.
Right? So, this happens when you're
maybe mis- mixing two different tasks
that didn't really overlap. Or you've
kind of got some outdated comments
either in the code or that you've made
to the agent. Or even worse, what I've
seen a lot of people do is they start
walking down the road with an agent and
then realize,
"Hey,
we're down the wrong path. We've made a
lot of wrong decisions." And they try to
steer the agent back.
But the problem is again, the agent is
not doing real reasoning like you and I
as a human. Right? It's taking all that
context every time.
And it may get lost in the middle or
even see some of those negative things
that you had before as still part of the
context.
And you see those negative patterns
creeping back in if you're not careful.
That's why it's better, you know, to not
let these things kind of compound.
But also, you know, always start a new
session once you realize things are kind
of off the rails.
Right? Because not only is context
expensive,
the more we have doesn't always mean
better quality. In fact, at a certain
point there's a tipping point where it
means worse quality.
And bad context can corrupt the output.
So, the real critical thing for
engineers is to manage the context. And
what does that mean?
Well, one, I think it means persisting a
lot of information outside of the
context window so that we can bring it
in, right? So, this is things like
scratch pads for things we're working
on, memory files, the agents.md,
those kinds of files that help the
agents have context to what you're
working on.
We also need to be very selective when
we're
selecting that context. So, that means
only pull in what's relevant for this
step of the problem, right? Don't just
pull in everything that might be useful.
And so, that could mean,
you know, things like bringing in the
right at mentions for files that we're
referencing. That could mean making sure
we don't have unnecessary MCP servers
enabled. Uh and it means, you know,
making sure that the agent has the right
data and that we as a human have curated
that data for the agent.
And then, as it's getting bigger and
that that window gets bigger, we want to
summarize and trim and compress that
context, right? If we've gone through a
whole big deep dive and debugging
session with the agent and now we think
we have the problem and the solution,
well, that's great. It might be time to
compress that context and just focus the
agent back in on, "Okay, now we
understand this problem. We're going to
go fix it."
Uh and then the other most important
thing is to isolate context. And I think
this is why we've seen this huge rise in
the past six or eight months of parallel
agents because splitting work across
several agents or several sessions can
help things not accumulate. And really
drive this kind of task separation.
And again, if you think about it, aren't
these all of the same things that I
would tell a brand new engineering
manager about about managing a junior
engineer?
Like the story I tell here is a when I
was early in my career, I spent a lot of
time as an engineering manager and
product manager before I
went into the dark arts of developer
relations.
And in my first job ever as an engineer
manager, I was at a healthcare software
company.
And there was this new thing coming out
called an iPad. And that dates me a
little bit. Um but it was it was
released in the market and we thought
this could be a great place to collect
patient history, you know, that form you
have to fill out every year at the
doctor. It's very critical to assessing
a lot of your, you know, risk of
disease.
Um but having to fill it out from
scratch every time is is not fun.
And so, I designed in this other archaic
tool that some people may have heard of
called Balsamiq, basically a wireframing
tool, a wireframe of what this would
look like.
Now, that wireframing tool used things
like Comic Sans and like silly smiley
face icons as placeholders.
And a lot of other stuff like that that
you'd expect from just a wireframe.
And I handed that to a set of interns
that we had working for us that summer
thinking this is a great green field
project for them to take some time on.
And you know, a few weeks later I got
back a working prototype
and the font was Comic Sans and there
were silly emoji placeholders.
And that's because that's what the spec
had in it.
And so so whose fault was that?
Obviously it was not the intern's fault.
It was my fault as an engineering
manager not giving the right context to
those junior engineers as to what's
important, what's not, and what we
really need to focus on and what problem
we're solving.
And so I think the habits that can tie
all of that together
are you don't need to think about all
four of those things for every task, you
just need to think about doing one task
per session,
keep an eye on your context meter, and
if you're in doubt and it feels like
things are off the route rails, you're
probably right.
So start a new session, ask it to
summarize the session for a new agent.
Turns out that AI is really great at
writing prompts for AI. So if you've
worked on something with an agent for a
while,
have that agent summarize where you're
at,
you can now read it, make sure it
matches with your understanding and then
start a new
uh session with just that right context.
Again,
it's a little bit of art and a little
bit of science.
So how do we put this into practice?
Well, I think there's a lot of
workflows, there's lots of things
written out there that you can read.
I've even compiled a lot of them at
path.kilo.ai.
It's a where you can find like all of
these kinds of trends and ideas and
workflow patterns that have been talked
about.
But what I think I keep coming back to
is is maybe one of the simpler ones
and that's the research plan implement
loop.
Right? And I think this really helps us
solve for a lot of like classic mistakes
that people do when they pick up agentic
engineering for the first time or pick
up AI to help
try to do some engineering.
Um and what most people do is say, "Hey,
help me implement this feature. I want
it to do X and Y."
And you know, these large language
models are very good at outputting lots
of code. In fact, when I joined Kilo
Code over a year ago,
I made a pronouncement that we would
never have our website be
just prompt and a whole lot of code
flying by.
Makes for a great demo and you've seen
lots and lots of coding agents that
maybe that's how they show it off.
But I think the reality is jumping
straight into code like that can cause a
lot of wrong assumptions, it can waste
even more time rather than saving time,
and just create a lot of frustration.
And it really creates that kind of
paradigm that we've seen where people
are kind of anti-AI or think that AI is
not a useful tool because they've jumped
right in and gotten, you know, put
garbage in and gotten garbage out. Uh or
maybe it's been a while since they've
used it, right? I mean, if you think of
the the Will Smith eating spaghetti when
it comes to AI videos, that's come a
long way in just the past two, three,
four years.
You know, the same is true of the AI
coding models, but you have to do what
works to give them the best chance at
getting a great result. And what that is
is first understanding the problem
really well and making sure you and the
AI agent can understand the problem
really well.
Then laying out explicit steps for
implementing that
uh that those changes or fixing that
problem.
And only then do we jump to the
implementation phase where we're writing
code.
And Dex Horthy has a great uh phrase
that he says here, which is a bad line
of research can potentially be hundreds
of lines of bad code.
And so we're really going to focus in on
how do we get the research and the plan
in place
in order to make give ourselves
the best chance of having great code
come out.
So in that first phase, we're going to
use a tool that is only going to be
focused in on research. And so for Kilo,
we call that ask mode.
And the reason we call it that is
because the ask mode can't actually do
anything. It can only chat. It can't
write files. It can maybe read files if
you let it,
but it can't, you know, start trying to
code a solution.
And so instead of trying to to code a
solution from the beginning, we're going
to first try to understand the system.
You know, how does it actually work
today? Where are the right files that
are going to be involved? What are the
right paradigms that we want to mirror
or how does this differ from something
that we have already?
And you know, just kind of learn where
in the code base this this is going to
go and you know, how the data is going
to flow through the system and how it's
going to change with our change as well
as like any edge cases we can need to
consider, right? AI is really great at
brainstorming and so it can help you
kind of brainstorm those things and make
sure you've really covered all of your
bases.
And then once you're done that research,
what's going to come out of that is an
actual output document that shows the
the details of that research that you
can then read and basically agree with
and understand, "Hey, this this matches
my understanding of the problem.
I think we're ready to move on to the
plan."
And so then once we've reviewed that as
a human, now we can say, "Okay, let's
outline the next steps. What kind of you
know,
files are we going to create or or
change? Maybe there's some code
snippets, but not always is it a good
idea to have a code snippet in the plan.
We are definitely going to include like
how is how are we going to verify and
know this change is correct? What are
the test either changes or additions
that we're going to make to know that?
And we're also going to be really
explicit at the plan planning phase
about what is in and out of scope, what
is going to change, what isn't going to
change.
And again, the output of that is going
to be a very clear plan file, right?
You'll see a lot of repositories
nowadays have a folder called plans.
Right? And we want to have that plan
file be step-by-step instructions with
specific changes that we're going to
make that have test commands to verify
it, that has a strategy for
understanding how it's going to change
the system. And it's going to be very
clear so that we can even use maybe a
smaller, faster, or cheaper model to
implement it because we've spent the
time in the research and plan phase to
really understand what we're going to be
doing once we get to
implementing the change.
And when we come to implementing the
change, we now can start over a new
session and give it just the plan
execution.
It allows us to keep the context in that
session very low. It allows us to
carefully review each change and I think
commit very frequently. Now, I used to
work at a company called GitLab for
many, many years. Uh so maybe I'm a
little biased towards Git, but I think
Git can be a huge helper here when it
comes to helping you slowly iterate and
understand the changes that the agents
are making.
I treat Git on my local machine kind of
like my own first pull request review
with my agents before I maybe put up an
actual pull request for my
uh you know, for my colleagues to look
at.
But I think again, it's critical to
understand here that human research at
the planning or sorry, human time at the
planning and research phases
is really the highest highest leverage
use of your time.
By the time you're implementing, you
want to have all that hard thinking
done.
Uh and that's really critical cuz again,
going back to Dex Horthy who's who's
spoken a lot on the subject and uh I I
highly recommend you check out his you
you know, videos of him on YouTube
talking about this.
He says very aptly that AI can't replace
thinking. It can only amplify the
thinking you've done
or the lack of thinking you haven't done
or you know,
the fact that you haven't thought it
through.
And so let's talk about how we can
figure our agents kind of like one more
step down from this
this uh paradigm of research plan
implement to really make sure we do
this.
So first we talked about modes and
customizations. We already talked about
these modes, ask, code, architect. These
modes that are specialized and focused
on the thing that we're trying to get
done. Right? Architect is maybe for
planning. Ask mode is for research. Code
mode is for actually implementing.
Uh then we also want to have, you know,
a set of rules that make sense for our
workspace, right? For the the repository
we're in.
Uh or maybe globally on our machine so
that we understand, you know, that we
have a certain set of rules that we
always want to adhere to.
Uh and agents are pretty good at loading
in and understanding those rules.
Uh but we have to have them written down
for them to have those in their context,
right?
And so I think a lot of the agent
behavior then
is are things that we want to tweak as
we're learning, right? How many Do we
want to do multiple agents at a time? Do
we want those agents to use work trees
so that we can then again, merge them
back in to our local uh repository
locally before committing them to to a
pull request?
Uh how much do we want to auto-approve,
right? So most agents have the ability
to tune, you know, what are the things
that it can do independently? What are
the tools it can use independently? Can
it read files? Can it read files inside
or outside of the workspace? Uh can it
run tests? You know, what can the agent
do autonomously without your
intervention versus what do you need to
approve?
Yeah, I think this is something that you
have to set up to be comfortable with in
the beginning and then also you need to
be comfortable changing as you learn how
to use these tools.
And then I think a good mental model um
for this agent configuration is maybe
kind of three distinct buckets, right?
We talked about modes, right? This is
that that role-based configuration, you
know, a behavior of an agent that we
want.
Uh but there's two other really key
things and that is the agents.md and
then skills.md that you'll hear about.
Uh and so what are those what's the
difference between the two?
Well, the agents.md is now quickly
becoming the de facto standard for where
all agents go kind of for their readme,
for the like always-on rules and details
about the project. Uh so I think it's
critical that your project has an
agents.md with a minimal amount of
information that an agent needs to know
about, you know, what are the
conventions that we're using, what are
the commands that we're using to get it
built or tested, and like what are the
requirements around testing,
uh or requirements that we need to be
sure check off before committing.
And then skills are kind of more of a
specific workflow, right? So there's
reusable kind of playbooks for agents.
So if there's something that you're
doing a lot, you're making motion
graphics with their motion often, or
you're
um you know, doing some sort of like
uh daily or weekly or monthly change log
compiling,
those kinds of things
are great to put in as skills that an
agent can then pick up when it needs it
to do those specific kinds of workflows.
And so typically those are on demand and
you say, "Hey, let's use this skill for
this task." Versus the agents is almost
always loaded into the context for the
agent, so it knows what's going on.
And then of course, I I work at
Kilocode, and so I've got some power
user tips there,
um but I think some of these many of
these apply, you know, regardless of
which agent you're using, but I think
they're critical as you kind of get
comfortable with those first kinds of
paradigms. How do I now customize this
and make it work for me? And one is
at-mentioning for context. So mentioning
files or commits or, you know,
things from the terminal that output.
Those kinds of things and bringing them
into the context quickly are really
helpful. Uh using slash commands to do
things like starting a new task when we
need to, or condensing the context when
it's getting too full.
Uh those kind of quick commands can help
us move a lot faster.
Uh we also can, if we're working in in
VS Code uh with Kilocode, we can select
uh a section of of code and right-click
and say add to Kilocode, and then that
context is brought right in there, and I
can then talk or ask or
uh questions about the that code, or ask
the agent to change a certain part about
that code. Uh and then of course, we
have autocomplete built in as well,
which I think is still useful,
especially because we also have it not
just in code, but as you're prompting.
And then kind of beyond the IDE, I think
we're seeing, you know, also this shift
this year in, you know, where else do I
want to be able to use this? In the CLI,
from my mobile phone, in a cloud agent,
directly in Slack. Right? The ability to
kind of use these agents wherever you
are is something that's becoming more
expected
uh of of everyone and everyone's agents.
And I think that's a good thing. I think
that means that we're starting to learn
how we can use this these agents again
more like a collaborator that's
everywhere that we need to be.
And then one other thing that I want to
talk about um are is getting other
context things in. First of all, model
context protocol, right? Context is
right in the name.
Um
the idea of this is, you know,
fundamentally these models originally
can only like
it receive input tokens and create
output tokens, right?
Uh and slowly but surely we've been
enabling them to use tools where they
can, you know, make tool calls out uh
and affect things in the environment,
like running tests.
Uh the MCP, the concept of MCP basically
expands this to say, "Hey, I want to
give other tools." Right? For instance,
the GitHub MCP gives the agent a lot of
tools to interact with the GitHub API,
look up pull requests,
um look up comments, look up issues, and
understand a lot more about your your
GitHub environment, right?
Um or context seven helps it look for
up-to-date framework documentation,
because of course, as you know, the LLMs
kind of have a cutoff date where their
knowledge cuts off, and then then
anything that's improved since then they
don't know about.
Um
so these MCP servers can be very
helpful, and there's there's thousands
of them out there.
Uh but the concern is that every one of
them is going to add at least some
information, right? Details about those
tools that it has to the system prompt
that gets sent every time uh you're
having an interaction with an agent. And
so you want to make sure, if you're not
actually using that, to disable it,
right? Let's say I have a Postgres MCP
that connects to my database, and I'm
doing a whole bunch of front-end work
that doesn't involve the database at
all. Well, that Postgres MCP is just
going to be wasted tokens, and maybe
even worse,
tokens that help, you know, kind of
confuse the agent and and not understand
that it's not supposed to touch the
database right now.
Uh so we want to be really careful to
not like overuse MCPs.
And then another thing we hear from
um
enterprises a lot is how do we work with
internal platform APIs?
Uh and I think that, you know,
there's kind of four different ways of
doing that. One, if there's already an
OpenAI open API spec for it, or Swagger
spec, use that.
If there's not, then convert it to
markdown so that you can save that
markdown, you know, in the agents.md or
somewhere else in the repository to
reference it.
Uh and if it's something that changes a
little bit more frequently, maybe you do
need to have like a reference URL that
you can pull in
uh and have the agent go pull every time
to see the latest and greatest.
Uh and then we've seen some customers
who, you know, have complex multi-step,
multi-system workflows, where building
their own MCP server might be the right
choice.
But, you know, one way or another, I
think the the key is to, when working
alongside Kilo or any of these agents,
you know, isolate your work from the
agent's work, and then review that
agent's work as a pull request, right?
That helps you understand, you know, how
can I
um
best review the code just like I would
review a junior engineer's code.
And so that's really the presentation
that I have on Kilo. We've got some
exciting new features coming up. We've
got, you know,
expanded across all these surfaces.
Uh we also have a big focus on Openclaw
and Kiloclaw and making a very safe way
to use um Openclaw agents.
Uh and so if you haven't taken a look at
Kilo, I've just a little plug at the end
here, visit kilo.ai,
uh and we'd love to get your feedback on
what we're building.
And you know, just kind of to give you,
you know, where do we go from here?
Again, I think you've kind of got to
pick a tool and get lots of reps, right?
We said earlier on that, you know, it's
part art and part science, and I think
that just means you need a lot of reps,
right? To kind of get the feel for what
can I trust the models to do, and what
can't I trust the models to do.
Uh and then try this research, plan,
implement, feedback loop. See how that
works for you.
Um and I think maybe you'll end up like
some of these other senior engineers who
have said, "Hey, look, I'm having more
fun programming now than I've had in in
years and years." Uh as we, you know,
farm out some of this tedious work to AI
agents and let our brains work on the
harder engineering problems.
Thanks.